a congressman is now formally publicly
saying he believes the current President
of the United States is a Russian agent
and I'm gonna talk about the use of the
word agent in a second because that's
important here so let's back up a moment
we had this FBI probe into whether
Donald Trump is a Russian asset and that
was opened pretty early on in Donald
Trump's presidency we talked about that
I believe it was at the beginning of
last week if not the previous week and
part of what we learned based on the
reporting of the New York Times on this
issue is that the FBI was worried about
Trump being a Russian asset pretty early
on in his campaign but they weren't sure
how they could open up an investigation
into that without the political
repercussions of it that might take
place but once Donald Trump fired FBI
director James Comey to interfere in the
Russia investigation the FBI felt that
this has crossed a line where now we
have more than enough cover to start
investigating Trump as a Russian asset
now I've said before I believe Russian
agent is simply not the right word here
okay I've seen no serious suggestion
that Trump is a Russian agent an agent
would be like an intelligence agent of
Russia or something much more formal
asset is a broader term asset could mean
Trump's compromised and under the
influence of Russia for example it could
mean that he has been influenced in a
way that he's not even aware of as as
making him an asset but in a way that
makes him useful to Russian interests as
someone in power in the United States in
any case I believe the right word would
be is he an asset not an agent
but Democratic congressman Eric's wall
well from California is now saying
publicly in interviews that he believes
Trump is a Russian agent check out this
video from an interview he did with
Margaret Hoover at what point you draw
the line and not accused the president
United States without any evidence of
being an agent of Russia yeah he's
betrayed our country and I don't I don't
say that lightly I worked as a
prosecutor for seven years and I
betraying the country by the way we want
evidence before you say that but you
said an agent of Russia he he works on
their behalf he since he met with
Vladimir Putin in Helsinki in July
where he took the interpreters now
service hasn't told any US official what
they discussed
he has taken us out of Syria which is a
top priority of Russia
he sought diminish or pullout the u.s.
from NATO and he's easing sanctions on
Vladimir Putin's friends who are under
investigation past sanctions against
Russia
he has armed Ukraine he has killed 200
Russians in Syria I mean those aren't
the actions of an agent of Russia either
he signed I think you know but
grudgingly sanctions against Russia
after Congress and people expressed
concern and he got backed into it but as
soon as he could he has pulled those
away and so what makes him an agent of
Russia that during the campaign the
Russians were offering and we saw this
in our investigation and Free Press
reporting and show this they were
offering their assistance to help him
they were reaching out you know whether
it was the Trump Tower meeting whether
it was you know the number of subject
line emails we saw that said you know
Russia Putin Trump let's connect them
whether it was trying to build a Trump
Tower and say in Felix Seder a Russian
American who worked for President Trump
saying if we connect Vladimir Putin and
Donald Trump we can engineer this and
make our boy president he never turned
down those offers in fact after it was
revealed that the Russians were
attacking our democracy he went to a
press conference and said Russia keep
doing it so what were so there's a lot
in there
sois well says Russian agent but what
he's describing is actually a Russian
asset again so I think it's a tactical
mistake to use the wrong word because
now swallow is going to get absolutely
crushed about that because again Trump
is not a Russian agent that doesn't make
sense based on what we know he's a
Russian asset if anything and that is
the word that really should be used but
when I watch this Pat what I see is
Eric's wall well a guy who's on the
House Intelligence Committee who knows a
ton of stuff that is not public I see a
guy who has come to his conclusion that
Trump is a Russian asset on the basis of
stuff that he has seen behind closed
doors and he is trying very hard to make
a case for that only with what is okay
to say publicly and that that's what I
see here this is not a guy who by virtue
of his role on the house Intel committee
is going to make this allegation if he
doesn't think he has the evidence to
back it up it's just that he can't
really make the case
publicly because so much of what he's
seen is not public at this time that
very well may be the case but given the
fact that he can't offer up that
information I think it makes it fall
flat because it's gonna say that the guy
is a Russian agent I think you have to
present some supporting evidence to that
effect if you're going to go on TV and
spout that and I think at the end of the
day these words do matter
same thing when when Democrats like
Bernie Sanders and Alexandria Cosco
Cortes go out there and say that their
Democratic socialists when they're
actually Social Democrats I think I
think you're just opening yourself up to
criticism and it's completely an
unforced error I think it would have
been smarter or sois well first of all
to say Russian asset and not Asian and
to say listen I am privy to a lot of
classified information because of my
role and I can't actually talk about
that right now but where was the
evidence when Donald Trump claimed
Hillary Clinton committed crimes which
should put her in prison where was the
evidence when Donald Trump claimed that
Obama spied on him where was the
evidence that Obama wasn't born in the
United States when Donald Trump was
claiming that since when has evidence
been required to make outrageous claims
I actually happened to have knowledge
here you will find out of it and do it
find out about it in due course or
something like that and most importantly
he really should have said asset and not
agent because agent has one meaning an
asset has another meaning and I've seen
nothing to suggest that Donald Trump is
a Russian agent so certainly at minimum
a tactical mistake by Eric's wall well
but hopefully at some point we'll know
why he's come to that conclusion